et l'invité du jour c'est vous
aujourd'hui fatou diop bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
écrivain franco sénégalaise et vous
signez marianne face aux faussaires qui
est sorti il ya quelques jours chez
albin michel et voilà qu'on voit à
l'antenne en écho à un autre texte qui
était sorti lui il ya cinq ans lui aussi
quelques jours avant la présidentielle
et qui s'appelait et qui s'appelle
toujours marianne porte plainte vous dit
fatou diop que vous écrivez en général
sur ce qui vous empêche de dormir
qu'est ce qui vous a empêché de dormir
au point que vous ayez besoin d'écrire
ce livre mais les faussaires justement
ceux qui crient au déclin qui crient à
la séparation de la société française
alors que moi je rêve de rassembler
c'est un pavé dans la mare ce texte
tentait d'une forme de colère ou de
douleur vous nous direz peut-être de
quoi il en retourne de voir le débat
politique monopolisé écrivez-vous du
moins jusqu'à ce que la guerre en
ukraine on va y revenir écrase le reste
un débat politique monopolisé dans cette
campagne par des questions identitaires
oui par les loups je pense que ceux qui
font une fixation sur l'identité
française qui la voudrait monolithique
il oublie l'histoire de france ils
oublient que toute société est la
résultante de son passé la france s'est
répandue partout dans le monde et la
partager sa culture sa langue donc ce
n'est pas un hasard finalement c'est
marianne à des enfants de toutes les
couleurs la guerre on va y revenir un
instant la guerre on ukraine bien sûr à
forcer les candidats à sortir du bois
sur des questions internationales elle a
eu un autre effet qui nous ramène
précisément à des questions d'identité
quand l'accueil extrêmement spontanée et
généreuse des réfugiés d'ukrainiens en
europe de l'ouest a contrasté avec le
sort qui est réservé aux autres depuis
bien longtemps qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque je vous dis que sur les prêts
les vaches ne font pas de différence à
cause de la couleur de leur robe donc il
serait bien que les humains soit plus
généreux plus fraternelle il faudrait
atteindre cette maturité dans la
fraternité pour savoir que toute
personne fuyant la guerre mérite
l'accueil tout réfugié qui demande
l'asile mérite d'être accueillis écouter
protéger donc il faut aussi que l'europe
se disent qu'on les regarde on les
observe on voit comment ils traitent les
réfugiés et a même des gens qui ont osé
le péché de dire ouvertement à mais les
ukrainiens ce sont des réfugiés de
qualité donc alors je ne savais pas que
j'étais une habitante au bas de gamme
de fuyants ni la guerre ni la famine de
votre plein gré écrivez vous vous avez
posé vos valises en france il ya un peu
plus de 20 ans d'abord par amour la
sénégalaise que vous étiez est devenus
franco sénégalaise dix ans plus tard ce
que ça veut dire aujourd'hui d'être
franco sénégalaise s'est en partie
l'objet de ce livre oui parce que je me
dis qu'être franco-sénégalaise ce n'est
pas seulement une histoire de passeport
de porc d'aéroport est franco
sénégalaise c'est une condition
existentielle c'est à la fois être
sensible à la situation de l'europe ce
qui se passe en ukraine aujourd'hui je
me sens concerné ce sont mes frères mes
soeurs qui sont dans la souffrance donc
je me sens concerné par cette détresse
là et en même temps j'en parle les côtes
de l'afrique donc je suis toujours celle
qui traverse entre les deux continents
et qui aime les deux donc la paix
intérieure réside dans le dialogue de
ces deux cultures dans la paix la
fraternité altice et culture l'absence
de paix mais l'absence de père et c'est
invivable c'est la fin de notre humanité
parce que il faut de l'espoir pour
continuer d'avancer il faut de l'espoir
pour créer il faut de l'espoir pour
créer de la richesse on parle de progrès
de progrès quels progrès possibles quand
il ya la guerre partout quels progrès
quand il ya la famine donc ouvriers le
corner virus est récent on a déjà trouvé
un vaccin et le paludisme tue des
millions de gens depuis des années des
années à trouver un exemple les plus
jeunes en tout cas contre le palu c'est
un espoir mais le corona est une leçon
l'assignation identitaire a dit vous
c'est un valider l'aptitude de l'autre à
se définir a fortiori dans sa complexité
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
en ça le trait d'union qu'il y a entre
franco et sénégalaises dans votre cas
est capital oui parce qu'il ya une
espèce de soupçons d'infidélité ou
d'absence de liens sincères avec la
patrie qui nous accueille on a laissé
une patrie derrière on continue à
l'aimer donc il ya les secteurs de
l'identité nationale qui voudraient que
nous renoncions à nos origines à nos
histoires familiales c'est marianne ne
demande à personne de devenir une
mutante mange pas une mutante je suis
une sénégalaise plus une française où
les autres diront à l sénégalaise mais
les françaises mais je préfère ce qu'ils
disent et les sénégalaises et françaises
c'est l'addition qui me constitue donc
je suis une fille de l'adjonction plus
plus plus ça me semble plus intéressant
que les gens qui voudraient divisé
l'identité de marianne les secteurs
alors précisément ces secteurs ils sont
du côté des identitaires pour revenir à
la campagne électorale et à ses
candidats eric zemmour et et marine le
pen en tête on en parlait à l'instant
mais ils sont aussi écrivez-vous du côté
des opportunistes victimaire oui qui
sont-ils concrètement et en quoi sont
ils selon vous partie du problème
j'appelle opportune victimaire les gens
qui se mêlent aux mouvements militants
mais qui les détournent à d'autres fins
vous savez toute lutte contre la
discrimination contre la l'homophobie et
le racisme même la grossophobie toutes
les contre ceux ci contre ceux ci c'est
normal de lutter pour demander la même
dignité pour tout le monde ce que je
n'accepte pas c'est quand on dit à toute
une génération que leur avenir est
oblitéré que le passé a déjà décider de
leur avenir ouais je considère que nous
devons étudier l'histoire de l'afrique
l'histoire de l'esclavagé ce que
l'histoire de la colonisation mais tout
cela doit servir de leçon pour être
justement à la hauteur des défis
d'aujourd'hui et les problèmes
d'aujourd'hui nous devons leur donner
leurs vrais noms pas toujours recourir
au passé forcément pour justifier des
choses qui ont d'autres raisons
d'exister aujourd'hui donc les
opportunistes ce sont ceux qui prennent
les mouvements militants comme des
podiums ou se faire un nom je suis
contre ça parce que c'est un calcul qui
ne libèrent pas la masse et moi je rêve
d'une afrique debout fière un tiers et
fraternelle vous parlez de l'histoire
bien sûr de l'esclavagé de la
colonisation vous dites qu'il faut
pacifier les mémoires pour avancer
pourtant pour des générations d'enfants
d'immigrés aux immigrés de la première
génération mais aussi dans les rapports
de la france avec beaucoup de pays
notamment ses anciennes colonies
africaines c'est un problème du présent
et pas nécessairement du passé oui parce
que il ya le paradoxe de cette demande
d'intégration
combien d'autochtones de mal tout le
temps l'intégration mais qui laisse tous
les efforts aux autres loups qui sont
venus nous pouvons faire un effort
d'adaptation mais quand vous renvoyer à
quelqu'un tout le temps pas statut
d'étranger étrangers par définition ce
provisoire donc quand vous êtes
naturalisés vous n'êtes plus étranger or
on dit immigrés de première deuxième
troisième génération ce qui est un non
sens linguistique parce qu'en fait les
immigrés c'est celui qui a quitté sa
terre d'origine avec sa petite valise et
qui s'en va lui les immigrés une fois
installés les enfants auxquels il donne
naissance ne peuvent en rien hérité de
ce statut d'autres marianne doit savoir
qu'elle a des enfants arabes des enfants
loire des enfants blancs et que tout ça
composent la société française mais
quand vous êtes noir ou arabe on vous
renvoie toujours à d'autres origines
vous avez parlé de monsieur qui
qui se proclament défenseur de
l'identité souveraine de la france est
révolu les candidats à la présidence
voilà ce qui le rattache à la france est
exactement ce qu'ils ont rattaché à la
france c'est la colonisation le lien
culturel lui il est là à chercher à
épépinez le pedigree des autres et bien
quand on interroge le pedigree des gens
aimeront soumet le sien à l'examen il
est qui lui il vient d'où il aurait pu
s'appeler mohammed vi qui vient
d'algérie alors il dit mes paroles
d'origine berbère et lula lors et bien
moi mes parents sont ces réunions minka
du 6e salon je suis certain autant que
je suis alsacienne et jean suffire comme
on remet ça sera ma dernière question et
en quelques mots fatou diop de la
complexité et de la nuance dans le débat
mais vous savez moi je dis que j'écris
pas en puissance
donc je ne parlais plus qu'ils signent
les deux créés mais j'ai le droit de
rêver de révolte et de partager mon
désarroi donc voilà je vous écrit des
livres pour parler de tarte aux pommes
ou des orchidées mais je peux aussi
écrire quand il ya des choses qui m'ont
avoir dans la société que je voudrais
meilleur marianne en fait on lui demande
plus parce qu'elle promet beaucoup de
choses qui sont très très grand des
valeurs humanistes donc liberté égalité
fraternité vous pouvez dire ça partout
sur cette terre tout le monde sera
d'accord et donc moi je lui demande
toujours de les défendre ces valeurs là
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit ce livre
tout en étant parfaitement consciente de
monter en puissance mais porté par une
forme d'espoir même toujours rassurez
moi merci beaucoup fatou diop le temps
nous a manqué mais on a dit l'essentiel
je crois marianne face aux faussaires
qui est sorti chez albin michel votre
pavé dans la mare commandiez à quelques
semaines aime bien sûr voté le 10 avril
prochain du premier tour de la
présidentielle quelque peu éclipsé par
l'actualité tragique ukrainienne dans le
sur laquelle on revient bien sûr dans
quelques minutes dans le journal de 8
heures et demie avec des nains ok merci
encore une journée à vous on se retrouve
juste après la pause